Well,
good afternoon to everybody here in mountain view.
Thanks for coming out to our Googlers tuning in at offices around the world.
Good day to you as well.
Um,
so we're in for a treat today.
Uh,
the gentleman to my right probably need no introduction,
but I'll still have ventured eight to try to give him one.
Anyway,
uh,
gentleman to my immediate right is none other than director cow Patrick Alvarez.
He's an la based.
He's a feature director,
writer,
producer and editor.
The Stanford prison experiment,
which we're here to talk about today.
Marks his third film as a director in 2010 he won the someone to watch award at
the independent spirit awards for his directorial debut.
Easier with practice.
The Stanford prison experiment was at this year's Sundance Film Festival and the
Nantucket Film Festival and I think at one,
two awards at Sundance.
Yup.
Okay.
Very cool.
Exciting stuff.
And Gentlemen,
to my further rights is Phillip Ge Zimbardo Phd,
Aka doctors z doctors and Barto.
Um,
he's one of the most distinguished living psychologists having served as
president of the American psychological association,
designed and narrated the award winning 26 part PBS series,
discovering psychology,
which hooked me into psychology as a high school student,
a and has published more than 50 books in 400 professional and popular articles
and chapters among them shyness,
the Lucifer effect,
Lucifer effect,
the time cure,
and the time paradox.
He's bit of a,
a Google toxic Google veterans,
so we're excited to have him back here.
He's a professor emeritus at Stanford University.
He spent 50 years teaching and studying psychology,
received his phd in psych from Yale University and his areas of focus include
time,
perspective,
shyness,
terrorism,
madness,
and evil.
Really glad you're introduced to me first.
They gave me a lot more to say here.
We'll close it up.
We'll wrap.
But I best known for his controversial Stanford prison experiment that
highlighted the ease with which ordinary intelligent college students could
cross the line between good and evil.
When caught up in the matrix of situational and systemic forces.
We'll talk a little bit of heroism letter,
which is what he's got in his shirt.
But uh,
let's get started.
Just so you guys know,
I'll do some Q and.
A.
We've prepared for the first half of the hour and then we've got a mic for a,
for the audience to do Q and a as well.
So the first part I want to talk to you doctor Zimbardo and kind of set the
stage for us.
Okay.
So your study spe Stanford prison experiment in 1971.
This is 10 years after Milgram's study began in 1961.
Um,
what's going on at this time?
Why are studies like this so popular back then?
Well,
I should fry mentioned an interesting coincidence,
little Stanley Milgram and little Philipson Bardot,
sat side by side and James Monroe high school in the Bronx and in 1949,
950 and they had kids who were talking about situations that,
you know,
kids,
I grew up in the south Bronx,
he grew up in the north Bronx.
You know,
you know what,
in what way does where you go make a difference.
And we conclude it makes a big difference.
Um,
now his study in 1963 at Yale,
um,
uh,
used,
um,
adults,
20 to 50 year old men mostly and no car.
He said no colleges though high school students and there was no selection
factor.
They just anybody who,
who answered living in new haven,
Connecticut and they've got four bucks an hour,
uh,
for study on memory.
So,
so that was a lie.
So the idea was that he would recruit young men,
young and middle age men,
uh,
in what they thought was this study to help people improve their memory.
And there were,
the way they going to help is by hurting.
So there was,
uh,
another,
another participant who they didn't realize was the confederate.
So one,
so the real subject is the teacher that confederate is the student pupil.
Um,
and teaching,
give some to learn when I get it right,
you say good.
When they get it wrong,
you deliver punishment.
And the way you deliver punishers like pressing a button on a shock box,
the shock box has 30 switches.
Each starts with 15 volts and each switch increases by 15 volts.
The problem is that the confederate starts to make mistakes.
So it's a dumbed down.
It gets shocked more and more.
And there's a point at which the confederate begins to scream and yell and I got
a heart condition and everybody says,
I don't turn the experiment.
I didn't want to go on disparities in a white lab coat.
So that's the beat.
That's the authority.
Obedient and experiments simply says,
I'm sorry,
you must continue.
The teacher.
The,
the experiment requires you continue.
So in order to get out,
you had to say three times I quit,
I quit.
I quit once or twice is not enough.
And when it gets to 300 volts,
the guy is screaming and out of control and everybody says,
I don't want to go on.
So everybody verbally,
uh,
complains.
Everybody verbally,
uh,
denies wanting to go on.
The problem is,
what did they do?
Two out of every three of the thousand subjects goes all the way to 450 volts.
And that point,
the guy is unconscious could be dead.
So it really shocked,
shocked the nation Shockton world.
And the reason I did my study and then I'll get back to answering crow,
what was happening at the time period is it's rare that somebody says do bad
shit.
Okay,
you're in a group and everybody's doing bad shit.
You're in a corporation and people begin to cheat and lie and steal and Oh,
you play a role.
If you're a manager,
your role is you're the bully.
Um,
uh,
your,
the traditional husband.
So what we want to see what happens when you're in a situation where situational
forces push you in a negative direction and nobody says you should do good to do
that.
There was something about the sixties and seventies,
which for me,
I,
I miss because there was a time of revolution was time of questioning.
People are so it's a civil rights,
a happening and a antiwar activities are happening.
Um,
uh,
really the start of feminism.
So it was really a time,
a very,
for me,
a very exciting,
exciting period of,
of social change.
And I think Milgrom tied into that now.
I must say he was a little Jewish kid,
meaning in 1948 he was concerned,
could the Holocaust happen again here?
Could he and his family ended up in a concentration camp.
We said,
Stanley,
don't be stupid.
You know,
that's Nazi Germany,
you know,
we're Americans,
we're not that kind of people.
And He,
I was still remembering saying,
I'll bet they said the same thing before the Nazis recruited them to be in the
SS.
It could happen here.
So I see that.
Thank you for the context.
So in,
in the film and also in interviews,
you've said that you had no idea what to expect from your study.
So based on,
based on Milgrom,
did you not have an inkling that,
that what happened might've happened or that folks would respond to the
authority in the way that they did?
Well,
in Milgram's thing,
it's really a one on one confrontation.
Somebody says,
do bad shit,
do it or you don't.
In our thing,
we're not telling them to do anything bad or good.
We say be a guard.
Well,
in your mind,
you know,
you've seen movies,
you've seen cool hand Luke ac and heat up at night and seen other movies that
guards had power.
Okay.
Um,
so essentially we assumed that they would be verbal abuse.
And the question is how long would it take?
Again,
nobody wanted to be a guard,
as you'll see in the film because guards were like,
uh,
police spent who in a seventies were called on college campuses to break up
antiwar rallies.
So cops,
police,
policemen,
cops are pigs.
I ain't going in those days.
Um,
and so essentially it's that in our study,
um,
it was difficult for the kids to get into the role of guards.
They put on military uniforms,
which felt awkward at first.
And you'll see the opening scenes people,
the audience laughs at the opening scene.
You know,
they didn't want it.
They didn't want to be in that role.
And it took one day before everything changed as you can,
as you saw in the movie.
And Kyle,
we'll talk about that transformation a day too.
I see.
Okay.
And not to give too much away from the come.
A lot of us were there last night.
We had a screening just just down the street.
But um,
two quick questions there.
One in the film,
as you're sitting in one of the hallways,
I guess one of your colleagues come and he kind of confronts you and he says,
what's your independent variable in this study?
Would you answer that for us now?
Yeah.
So,
so in every experiment there's something you very manipulative and there's
something you measure when you do a correlational study.
You mentioned two things.
Uh,
so I wanna know,
um,
are extroverts,
uh,
more open to new experience than introverts.
So I give scale of extraversion openness to experience and I do a correlation to
say,
do they go together and in experiments that the thing you want to see is,
does behavior change?
And that's called the dependent variable.
It's dependent on what your manipulate and what you manipulate is called the
independent variable.
Just the terms.
So in this case,
the manipulation was random assignment of a group of 24 students have to be
guards and have the prisons in the movie.
They do that thing of flipping a coin.
But in fact there's a table of random numbers that you give everybody a number,
then you pick out the number of prince and the president going.
So the reason you do that is at the beginning of this study,
they should be no systematic difference on any dimension between prisoners and
garden and the height and weight and,
uh,
emotional background,
etc. Wonderful.
Thank you.
And then the last thing here,
just to set the context,
what are the results of the study?
What if people don't know?
What did you learn?
What'd you take away?
Yeah.
Uh,
what's interesting about this study,
it's been called infamous controversial,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
That's after the fact.
There was in 1971,
Stanford University had one of the very first human subjects research committees
that I submitted this study too.
And every student filled out in informed consent to say,
I will be an experiment in which,
you know,
uh,
there'll be high stress for,
there'll be minimally adequate diet,
um,
you know,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I can leave the experiment if I,
when I,
I can,
I can terminate my,
my performance or participation,
uh,
simply by saying I,
I quit the experiment or something like that.
For me,
that's a magical phrase.
How to use those words.
I quit the explorer.
If you say I want out there wasn't good.
And so they fill out that form.
The problem was before you knew the results,
it was kids playing cops and robbers in the basement of Stanford University.
What could happen?
Nothing.
If anything,
what they said was,
you've been 70 the committee,
you need it to have a fire extinguisher because there was only one entrance is
no windows.
So if there was a fire and you'll see in the movie that's happened to this
thing,
they use the fire extinguisher against the prisoners.
Um,
you know,
so in hindsight you say,
wow,
it's really unethical.
People suffered.
How could anybody allow this?
They couldn't imagine as I couldn't what happened in two days.
Um,
and I,
it's not clear in the movie,
but on day,
at the end of the day one I told my graduate students and my team,
we've got,
if nothing changes,
we're going to end this and nothing's happening.
I mean,
it's,
it's so awkward.
It's embarrassing to sit and then day two prisoners revolved and suddenly
everything changes.
Wonderful.
Thank you.
This is for both of you,
the review on,
so how'd you get involved in the project?
Why,
why this film was time?
Talk to us about how that happened.
Well,
you know,
the uh,
uh,
for me and the,
and then
we can,
I'll backtrack a little bit to then with Dr Zimbardo's initial involvement.
I,
the script there,
there had been,
there has been,
or you can chime in at any point and I guess the project had been pretty much
since the experiment happened.
Someone has been trying to do a film out of it and you know,
there's been various iterations.
There was the writer of in the heat of the night,
we met you and brought you down to Los Angeles.
This is back in the 70s,
you know,
then in the,
there was another version.
So at some point then there was a version of the 90s that Leonardo Dicaprio is
going to do before titanic happened.
Um,
it was gonna be him and Vanessa del Toro.
and then there,
and then,
and then it led to this version happening and there was this producer who's,
who's from,
from,
from the area named Brent Emery,
and he reached out to you and he,
um,
yeah,
it took an option on the,
on the rights of the story and piece together.
They got,
they got Chris Mcquarrie involved who has a movie coming out in two weeks about
the new mission impossible movie.
And,
and he brought in a guy,
he writes with sometimes some Talbot.
So Tim started writing the script at the same time.
Then that filled was writing the Lucifer effect.
And so they were always in touch with each other,
sharing the research,
sharing the documents,
everything.
It was sort of like a perfect little storm for Tim to write the script.
And the first thing he did was like,
throw everything in there and just said,
okay,
let's just start.
I've read it and it's like a 300 something pages,
whatever,
280 page script did it?
Yeah.
It starts with waking up on the morning of the experiment ending and put in
every detail.
And then really I think the writing of it for Tim and what Tim did so well was,
okay,
what do you,
what do you pull out and an effort then who are the people we follow and the
experiment to,
you know,
where's the structure?
And it really became a,
I think a,
um,
an act of,
of,
of structuring a story around a lot of characters.
And then the project got cast off.
I had a,
what was a,
not a star,
you know,
kind of probably the equivalent of the cast we have now.
It was like Ryan Philippi and Jesse Eisenberg and Giovanni Ribisi and Channing
Tatum.
And you know,
at the time,
yes.
Before they became famous.
I mean,
yeah.
I went down and met with all these guys and they all have become famous,
young,
accurate,
and it was,
you know,
13 years ago.
Yeah.
And uh,
I think could,
he couldn't raise the money.
Yeah,
it was,
they were trying to make it a much bigger,
a bigger budget film.
It was a different time,
independent films in a very different time.
I mean,
this was,
I was just going into college at the time and I'm remember reading about the
project and it didn't come together as hundreds.
I mean,
in the time I've been talking,
you know,
five movies have died in Hollywood,
it's that kind of people that have the billboards,
how many people have died from smoking this year.
It's like,
you can do that same with Hollywood projects and it didn't happen,
but the script was so well,
well appreciated that the word of the script kind of always lingered around or
you read these articles of the great unproduced scripts are,
and it was always on there.
And Brent always held onto the rights.
The producer I mentioned earlier and this actor for my first phone,
Brian Garrity,
who's one of the stars of the hurt locker and a bunch of other films.
He had audition prob probably had addition for the film,
you know,
10 years earlier in 13 years earlier.
And they were,
he was friends with Brendan,
they were talking one night and Brent that along story short,
long story long Brent was like,
oh yeah,
I was still trying to get the Stanford prison experiment movie made and Brian
was like,
oh you should send it to my friend Kyle.
And some of the point of that whole story is that it really like sometimes these
things are,
here's this project that when people had been laboring over 40 years and it just
came down to like two guys sharing a drink and Ben,
someone being like,
Oh I should send that to my friend.
And then I read the script and started to really read about the experiment,
learn about it,
realize that the script had stayed so true to what the experiment was.
And from there I got involved with the project.
This was a few years ago.
And since then it's,
I took off,
I took a little time away to make an effort to make the film I made before.
Uh,
and then,
but it's really been it for Hollywood terms,
it went by three years for a film to get made as short.
I hate to say that,
but it is a really short period of time.
I see.
So,
uh,
this is a question that came up a little while ago and discussion and the
question was why not a documentary wide drama and is it because you inherited
the project after it was already written as a drama or,
no,
cause I mean I got sent,
you know,
scripts or bio pics.
So people's lives are books and you know,
all the time.
And you have to,
I think when it's something that's contemporary IEE,
there's video of it and there's interviews of the time and there's a book's been
written,
you know,
we're not talking about something that's totally undocumented.
You say,
okay,
well why,
why do this?
Why are you doing this as a film?
I think a lot of people make movies and the rationale is based on true people
are biopics are situations and the rationale is,
well there just hasn't been a movie yet so you've got to do it.
And that's not enough for me.
And so when I looked at the documentary,
the quiet rage,
the documentary that doctors and Bartow made about the experiment,
and I read the book,
I felt that they had done such a good job encompassing the studious nature of
the experiment.
But what those,
those couldn't do and they wouldn't be able to,
they wouldn't be as good and materially as they are,
is try to create the more experiential or the more emotional,
some something that an actor can bring to the film.
And so,
you know,
you watch the footage and just like in the film,
it's just one camera at the end and it was very expensive to run video in 1971
so there's,
there is quite a lot of footage,
but not everything is a lot of audio recordings.
It just felt like there was this opportunity to literally get inside of that
space and hopefully maybe illuminates some,
some more of that,
that they emotional capacity,
that emotional effect,
this experiment had on people.
I see.
So how did you do the casting?
How did you cast Dr Z and all that?
I mean,
we started with the kids actually,
so it was,
you know,
it's 25 leads,
which was really unusual for a low budget movie.
I mean,
it's unusual for any movie,
but you know,
and,
and I,
and I saw it,
I saw them all as leads.
I didn't want to say,
Oh,
well,
that guy doesn't really do much,
so he's not an issue.
You know,
we'll just get some central casting.
I wanted it to be each person.
You could train the camera on them and the seat could become about them.
And,
um,
and we,
uh,
and you know,
so we,
it took like a law.
It was a long time.
We were casting as we were financing.
So I basically started just meeting with these guys.
You know,
I had it,
I had a list of people I knew I wanted to be in the movie and I started meeting
with them,
trying to figure out their temperaments.
You know,
I didn't want to get,
young actors can be really,
really volatile and it really great way,
you know,
they can be those guys that just want to dive in and be really methody and want
to like only be called,
you know,
the character's name.
And there's so much ambition there and it's a really great thing and it's really
great thing if you're making a movie where you can give them all the attention
and comforts and things that come along with that.
But when you've got,
you know,
25 of them around,
there's no time for that.
So really I was,
I was like vetting them.
I guess I was doing like psychological betting on them to see how they would be.
So you know,
the one,
the hot shot kid who comes in and sits at lunch and he goes,
yeah,
you know,
he'd be like,
unwraps his cigarettes out of it,
back on his pocket.
And he's like,
no,
I studied Meisner and I did all this and this is,
these are the techniques I like to use it say like,
that's not the guy that's going to work.
He's incredibly talented.
But,
and then we started doing and we,
we got some of the guys,
some of the guys in the bigger parts involved initially.
And then as we were making the film trying to cast the Zimbardo part,
it's really,
it's tough.
You want someone who can evoke that feeling,
but you don't try to do mimicry,
but you want it to.
Also,
as much as we were recruiting the experiment,
try to match that kind of feeling.
And I've just always loved Billy Crudup.
I've always,
he's always been one of my favorites.
I think he's under utilized,
I think is underappreciated.
And,
and he's just incredibly talented.
And unfortunately,
I just made a movie.
I had made a movie with Corey Stoll,
who is so weird to see him.
Oh,
he's an ant man.
And the same weekend,
like blowing things up in a CG stuff.
But he,
uh,
Corey had just done a movie with Billy and had told Billy that he really liked
working with me.
So when the script came around a Billy with my name on it,
you know,
he was interested.
But the interesting thing connects to what you just said was when I first sat
down with Billy,
his hesitation was,
um,
he said,
well,
I just don't understand how did they not know this was gonna Happen?
And I was,
it was sort of,
that was his big thing that was holding him back from maybe saying yes to the
project.
And I remember it was like,
it was like an 8:00 AM meeting cause he had a plane to catch and I was like
tired.
And I was like,
and it like one of those weird moments where it dings and I was like,
well look,
he didn't know it was going to happen because the Stanford prison experiment
hadn't happened yet.
You know,
this was the thing that defined it.
That's where it's not an activity.
There was no,
there was no point of reference.
And,
and I think that was the thing that sorta got Billy on board.
And if you can,
it's like,
if he's just one of those guys,
if you can work with them,
it's like a highlight,
you know?
And I was really glad he,
he did.
I was really glad he did the movie.
And it was really good to all these guys.
I mean,
as rather for Ezra Miller,
the first time I met on the film I was,
so,
I said,
you know,
if we don't make this movie with Ezra Miller were like making a mistake.
He's walked,
he walked from 1971 into 2015.
Like,
it's bizarre.
He's,
he's not of this era.
And He,
um,
and he,
and you know,
but when we put this cast together,
our dream was to build a cast like the outsiders,
you know,
one of these from dazed and confused where you look back 10 years and you know,
we were always say that we look back 10 years,
you're not going to leave.
All these guys were in the same movie.
And really it's been like 10 months.
You know,
we didn't,
we didn't expect that.
We didn't know Ezra was going to be the flash.
And now that you lead in the Harry Potter,
one of the new leads in the Harry Potter that spin a Harry Potter spinoff and a
shared a cyclops and key only has the maze runner like all these guys have.
These are all things that happened after we made the film.
And part of that is engineered.
Part of that's luck and part of that's,
yeah.
I don't know the part of that Mojo or something,
you know,
and um,
and so it was a really,
it was a privilege and in like an embarrassment of riches to get to work with
all of these guys.
I seen you had them read both President God.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
When we have,
when we have people come in and audition,
when we did the more,
not open casting calls,
but you know,
would bring actors in for the most part,
unless I had something specific in mind.
But most of the times we just said they'd be sent,
we wrote scenes.
So I would combine some of the characters and just put some of the highlights of
moments that they needed to see.
And we just said to them,
you can come and read one,
you can read the other,
you can read both.
And it was an interesting thing.
And in some cases I would cast them against the part they thought they should
play.
Some cases they just did what they did,
they knew themselves,
you know,
so it was a weird thing and,
and a lot of cases,
it was really fun to try to take some of these kids who a lot of them were from
Disney shows and Nickelodeon shows and this is sort of their first more serious
feature and be like,
oh no,
you're going to be a guard.
You know,
you're like,
well,
I was a Hannah Montana,
his best friend.
But that's,
but then that's fun for them because they don't,
you know,
or like,
I remember like Jim James Walc uh,
was just so who plays with the Grad students was just so happy to uh,
to be like an a costume and to have like facial hair on a wig.
Like he just wanted that cause he's always playing like the handsome boyfriend.
He was just like,
it's real tight,
you know?
It's one of these things where you're giving these guys opportunities to do
something a little bit different and they just like chew it up.
I see.
Now obviously doctor Zimbardo was involved in the,
in the process.
Were any of the original subjects involved in the,
in the filming print?
Not at all.
No.
It was,
it was a careful and deliberate choice for me.
Part of it was that I felt what they would contribute to it.
That research had already been done right.
The eye.
He had done extensive followup interviews.
There's also interviews leading all the way up to just like maybe 10 years ago
lasts that you can see online.
But I wasn't,
while I felt we were representing doctors in Bartow directly and,
and his,
his wife,
doctor,
you know,
Doctor Christina,
mass lag or took the seniors of Otto directly.
I felt that everyone else,
it would,
it would do a disservice.
I mean,
I was trying to cast someone that looked like this person or can,
we weren't learning about them.
Right.
The only people we learn about outside of the experiment as him.
And so for me it felt like we,
when we changed all their names,
not even for legal reasons,
we changed them because I didn't feel,
I met a woman the other day,
she goes,
my brother was one of the guards,
my brother was John Mark and I got,
I couldn't even tell you who played him in the film because we were in order to
reduce it down into a two hour movie,
we were combining certain things people did.
I see.
So it was,
there were being defined.
These people were being,
characters are being defined by the actions they took inside of the experiment.
And I felt if I even connected the re the actors to the real people,
it just would have created this cacophony of,
uh,
of,
it just felt like we weren't actually making a movie about those individuals
were making movies about the actions they took.
And you know,
it's,
it's a tricky decision because you don't want to make a movie then where someone
goes and sees it and says,
well,
it was nothing like that and I wish you would have touched base with me and I
could have sold you this,
this,
and this.
But when there's so many,
it would have been on a diet.
I think it would,
I think it would have been endless pet pet.
I understand.
The other thing is m a number of the presidents that number of the guards to
this day said,
I was just acting and we just acting this.
It wasn't this situation.
In fact,
I just chose to be a prison who broke down.
They just chose to be evil guard.
And I tell them,
I said,
wow,
that's really great that I don't know any professional actor who can stay in
part eight hours a day,
day after day,
day after day.
So I think,
I think they were right.
They started playing a role,
especially the guy who plays John Way,
uh,
in a,
in a movie.
It's played brilliantly.
He was an 18 year old college freshman at Whitman College,
interested in drama and he saw the movie cool hand Luke Resa and he just chose
to be struggling Martin.
And it was a conscious choice on his part.
And,
but the point is,
you'll see,
once he gets into the role,
he becomes evil.
I mean,
in fact it's,
it's the definition of creative evil.
Uh,
and then he's,
he's stuck in that role and he's the one who says,
you know,
now the guards worked eight hour shifts so that they were home doing the usual
things.
Some of them,
Adam,
he,
and he's the one that says,
you come in,
you put on your guard uniform,
you put on a silver reflecting sunglasses idea.
I got from the,
what we call on Lou,
you have to Billy club,
you step out on the yard and you're a guard.
This is what he said later.
And then he said in a recent after Abu Ghraib prison,
our prison study got trips,
got intimacy again,
and he was interviewed and he said,
give it a little more time.
We guards could of got where they were and he said,
you know,
we were just getting off our jollies by being puppet tears and the prisoners
were our puppets.
This is 30 years later.
That is not acting,
that is taking the mentality he created 30 years,
44 years ago in into the present.
Well,
what does says to me is that there is power in what we call acting,
right?
This is what I talked to the auctions a lot about this.
I was like your professional role players playing unprofessional roleplayers and
this experiment and so you need to stay.
Yeah,
you need to stay the professional role player.
You know,
that was sort of the thing and that's where it was actually a really fun and
pleasant set.
And that,
especially when we were working with the kids because we were caught,
they were constantly aware of that.
But I think I'm mostly certain it's a Vonnegut quote,
which is embarrassing because everybody get a tattoo.
But when we said,
you know,
be careful what you pretend to be because you become what you pretend to be.
And I do think that that to me was a really interesting thing to see actors do
or they bring,
you know,
I wasn't trying to make a movie that was super aware of,
it's like that medic quality,
but there is something that it said it would be interesting for someone who is
in the acting world or writes papers about the acting theories to write,
okay,
what is,
you know,
where is it?
Or you hear these stories of actors who get lost in parts or whatever it might
be and it's really hard for them to return to their lives and their family
lives.
And it's an,
I think it's a really similar extension of what was going on there,
where it does start as fun and games and at a certain point,
if you're really good at it,
you know,
if you access yourself,
you lie to yourself enough.
And so,
you know,
our goal in making the film was to not get that far,
to get that far when the cameras are rolling and then you shut it off.
Give me close calls.
No,
no.
I mean we did when Chris is doing the pushups at the end,
uh,
you know,
he was just like,
look,
let's just do it,
you know.
So he was really doing the pushups.
Like Jack and Logan were really sitting on his back and um,
and he was like,
I can give you like three takes.
You know,
fortunately he was like the strongest.
He was probably the strongest guy in the cast.
So I had asked him physically.
Yeah.
But I had asked all the actors to stop working out.
You know,
cause I didn't want them to be,
there was a few scenes we shot,
they weren't in the film where they were had to bathe before the visitors come
and you don't,
people in the 70s didn't ha,
you know that was Matt Weiner is rural for his actors weren't,
that's what they always said.
The actors aren't allowed to go to the gym or run mad man because it's like
that's not how people looked at.
These actors only had two weeks notice,
you know,
most of them.
And we were so we had no rehearsal period or anything.
But so by the time he got to lunch we to lunch,
it was like a skate steak kabobs or you know what's for lunch.
And Chris,
his arms were like,
like he couldn't do it.
I had to like take the steak off him and you feel bad.
But,
but even then it was like,
he was like,
he was invigorated by it,
you know.
And so there was never a time where,
you know,
these actors were actually having fun.
I have,
I have like dozens of videos on my phone of when we were shooting the rate
stuff.
Nick Brown,
the really tall guy has as her against the wall,
like the in between takes when moving the camera just to keep their energy up.
They were just like play,
wrestle like I have like they were just having a blast,
you know,
it was like for them and that's fun.
That's what they were in there for.
That's what they love.
The Evil John Wayne Guard has him do pushups and then literally it's stepping on
his back,
pushing him down and then has to prison is sit on him while he's still doing a
pushup.
So that CMA and act really happened in the study.
But it was amazing that he could even do one and two people sitting on him.
And it was an interesting and speaking of the moments where it does,
this just popped in her mind.
You know Chris is struggling and probably legitimately starting to tear up and
he falls and we were and the producers are on my case cause we're union project
and we're already in grace period.
And lunch and like,
we need to go.
And I'm like,
this guy is literally killing himself for us.
We need to not cut them off.
And Michael at the end of the take throws them back up against the wall and he's
like,
you can't even do one lousy push up.
And it was totally made the lineup.
And I was like the most,
he made it up right there,
didn't even think about,
he doesn't remember really saying it.
And it was like,
that is the cruelest thing I've ever heard of.
But you know,
it was,
it came from his character and it really wasn't to him.
There was still that lane ends,
but we didn't get it on camera.
So they were like,
we've got to break for lunch.
I was like,
I have to get that line.
there's no way I'm not going to shoot that line.
It's just,
you know,
they were calling for lunch.
I think people,
you know,
the grips are like fuck fast and they're like walking out and everything like
that.
And,
um,
and it was just,
you know,
you don't have to,
it's a weird thing because I like to follow the rules and a lot of,
a lot of the great filmmakers don't follow the rules,
you know.
But the thing I always do try to remind myself,
it's really hard in a movie like this where there's no much so little time.
But you know,
you here,
I worked for Warren Beatty for awhile and he's infamous,
hundreds of takes.
I've never done more than five takes this film.
We never did more than two or three if there,
there was no time to,
but you know,
one time I was like,
well,
why do you do so many takes?
And he goes,
well,
because everything that costs money here,
like the sets,
the food that they're getting,
the accuracy or the locations,
he's like,
the thing that costs the least amount of money is the film in the camera.
In this case,
the hard drive in the camera,
you know,
that's the cheapest thing there.
So why aren't you going to always keep on running?
And,
and there's,
there's a modified truth to that that you can harness without doing a hundred
takes.
How long they do the prisoner guard.
Was it two weeks?
Two and a half.
We were there two and a half weeks in that hallway.
And then we had like a week and a half.
A little,
yeah,
a week and a half in another building where all the outside stuff was very cool.
Well,
not to,
not to interrupt the,
the Mojo here,
but,
so we had a screening last night in,
in about 10 of us in a group went together.
There was a hundred of us,
10 of us in a group that I was with.
And I remember the movie movie ends,
the credits roll and there's just radio from
all my friends and I for quite a while.
And it's been a while since I've been to a movie where every one of my friends
and I were just blown away.
Everybody two thumbs up,
rave reviews loved it.
Now the first thing that came to us,
um,
as we're talking through it is about half of us were like,
you know what?
I bet you it was that intense.
I bet you they didn't take too many liberties.
I'll bet you that's what it was like.
And half the folks were like,
I dunno man.
There's,
there's some stuff,
some of some of the stuff that I don't know if I could have taken it.
It's,
we're curious.
Um,
I could have taken it if I was there.
No,
they're saying that the what,
what in the film is,
is,
was made up or exaggerated.
It's nicely.
Yeah.
I mean,
he could speak a little more,
I'll let them speak a little,
literally will say that first and I'll say at night hi
to send something mean.
So they've compressed six days into two hours.
Now,
if anything,
there were a lot of dramatic things that happened in the real study that cut
deleted or they couldn't put in because of budget.
So there's nothing in the film.
Uh,
the,
none of the dramatic events in the film were made up.
They all mimicked.
But what really happened?
Wow.
The last scene I think puts together the three things that happened,
uh,
with,
separated,
uh,
buy more hours.
Um,
and so the last scene is riveting.
Overwhelming,
emotionally distressing.
Um,
and I'm worried the first time I saw that I said,
you know,
people are going to walk out of here in tears and say,
screw this.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I didn't pay 12 bucks to AI.
But,
but the goal is how do you transform that emotional distress to intellectual
self analysis?
What kind of guard would I have been?
What kind of president if I was,
if I was does it Mario character would not have ended it sooner.
She should,
he should he run it for two weeks and you know,
and then if this is,
if this is a simulated prison,
what must,
what must it be like to be in a real prison?
Rear guards have guns and power over you and,
and there are gangs know among the prisoners,
they're all gangs.
So our president is really more like a prisoner of war camp,
you see,
because everybody comes in the same time.
If you go to a prison,
there's a prison hierarchy.
There's guys who've been there 30 years,
this is the really bad guys.
His gangs,
there's black,
Hispanic,
skinhead white gangs.
Uh,
and,
and again,
if you come from,
if you,
if you're in prison and you're a young guy and you don't have a gang connection,
you're going to be a sissy.
The only question is how long.
So there's a whole dynamic,
which I know operates in system.
I studied prison,
which we didn't have.
So in a funny way,
it's like everybody starts in up in a prisoner of war camp,
so,
so that nobody has a history.
And the curious thing is that everyone got trapped in the expanded moment.
We bugged the cells and is 90% of all the conversation was about the prison,
the food,
the guards,
uh,
escape.
That means they knew nothing about each other.
They knew the all college students.
They didn't say,
you know what?
What school do you go to?
What are you majoring in and know nothing about the future.
What are you going to do when you get out?
Because all of them,
I got to start.
It's,
it's the end of summer school.
The all got to start in September.
And I should mention only two students were Stanford students.
One Garden when president,
because we did it in the summer and kids are finishing up summer school at
Berkeley and at Stanford,
at other places in the movie.
They mentioned Stanford three times.
So,
uh,
so some people believe that they were all separate suits.
That was done in the basement of Jordan Hall at Stanford.
But,
but it,
it's,
it's universe with college students.
I see white college students most forward
and my feeling to have the,
you know,
we obviously we stayed very true.
I mean,
I,
I I,
I have sort of like three prong thing to that.
One is the idea of saying something is based on a true story.
It means nothing anymore.
You know what I mean?
I thought,
I remember when I read,
when I read the script,
it was,
uh,
there was a movie around that time,
maybe it was last year or something,
or two years ago.
There was a movie with Eric Bana where he's like a cop fighting demons in New
York.
And it was like based on the true account,
based on a true story.
Maybe this guy says that happen,
but you know,
we know there are demons in New York.
And so,
and it really has talked about the exorcist,
I think,
you know,
and that's not a slam and that movie,
but that's sort of have that idea of the learner of the fear snow when we go see
the conjuring,
it's like in the summer of,
you know,
that kind of thing.
And,
um,
and for me I sort of felt,
but then we look at are really historical films like Lincoln brazenly make stuff
up and vote.
It changes public voting record,
you know,
when they're,
when they're voting on the,
uh,
you know,
at the end of the film when they're voting,
it just made it up for more tension.
So,
I mean,
that's something that we're there,
there,
you know,
and I feel,
and that's not even a slam on that movie,
you know,
it's so,
but for me,
I felt like when you look at that to say our film is,
you know,
I think fair,
when you say about 90% accurate,
I think there's an overwhelming number when the movies we look at or consider
historical probably live more in the 30% in many cases,
maybe the 10% or something.
So are we set our threshold much higher.
Now,
having said that,
I do think people who are there in terms of like a lot of the words and the
dialogue is coming from that.
I suspect,
and I haven't talked to anybody who was in the experiment.
I suspect they might say something like,
well,
it really wasn't that bad.
You know,
you watched the footage and it doesn't seem that bad,
but,
but that,
that's where what I was doing wasn't exaggerating it.
I was saying,
okay,
well I'm telling you to look at this by writing.
You start to question again.
What's your job as a film maker?
Not a documentarian,
but a filmmaker is to create an emotion.
And so I'm putting music in,
I'm putting cuts in,
I'm putting closeups,
and I'm doing all these things that say slow motion.
I'm doing,
I'm,
I'm doing and performance,
you know?
So you're doing things that say we're evoking this emotion.
It's not about trying to Hollywood eyes at or create something like that.
It's just trying to say,
this is the story we're trying to tell.
So if someone,
to me,
if someone came,
maybe someone will come forward and be like,
oh my God,
it was exactly the same and that'd be really enriching to hear,
but at the same or maybe a horrifying,
but you know,
but at the same time as someone came forward and wrote something,
it was nothing like that.
And then it's Hollywood doing again.
I'd be like,
well,
you have the right to feel that way.
But we also had the right to say,
okay,
here's this close up and here's this performance and here's the music and all
the things that it becomes friction.
As soon as you put a camera on the front of something,
that's as soon as you put a cot into something,
it becomes fiction in a way.
And I mean that,
speaking of narrative filmmaking that does,
that's a totally different conversation with documentary filmmaker get even then
nowadays,
documentary filmmaking,
especially the trend lately has been,
they've become,
it's become very blurry,
same friction.
But that's,
now,
this is a totally different,
but I understand speaking of emotion and invoking emotion.
So what I appreciated most about the film,
uh,
was not particularly just a,
the moments where things get really tense or sometimes there's,
there's,
there's physical force used.
For me it was when folks decide they're out,
when some of the prisoners decide I'm done with this.
And they start trying to find a way to scheme a way out of this.
I felt by the end of the film,
like I was in this theater and there were times where I wanted out of just like
the prisoners,
right.
And,
and it was so powerful.
Not,
not from the film,
I felt the prisoners.
What I'm saying,
what I'm curious about is,
is um,
what was the contract,
right?
Like were they,
were they able to get out?
Um,
was it paramount to keep them involved as long as possible?
And I'm saying it's a compliment.
I think it goes to do an incredible job of making you feel like the kids who are
on a filmmaking set.
And I think they actually contract is interesting thing to talk about was that I
started to before the movie from here,
you know,
we shot it in October,
premiered it in January.
So it was a really fast turnaround.
And I,
at the premiere,
you know,
we premiered it at Sundance and you know,
it went from 12 people haven't seen this movie to two hours later.
1300 people have now seen this movie.
And so that's an overwhelming feeling.
And it was weird because I was working so hard through the film to not to make
it brutal by the end,
but not so the first hour of the film I think has moments of liberty.
There's a lot of humor.
I really was telling the cast and working on the script to really make sure it
wasn't,
if it was harrowing 10 minutes in your,
we're fucked for the next hour and 50 minutes,
I don't want one of them.
You know?
And so it was,
for me it was about trying to earn that ending and,
and for it to crescendo to that as opposed to absolutely.
As opposed to being one of these movies that's just trying to brutalize you.
And so,
but because then even in the editing for instance,
it's 10 minutes,
the big final sequence and the first cut of the film,
it was 30 minutes and it wasn't a fat 30 minutes.
It was a lot more stuff happened.
And so,
you know,
we were trimming away to say,
well we don't want to make a movie.
That's so,
so when it was going to premiere,
my feeling,
what my fear was that people are gonna be like home.
You know,
we're seeing this before,
like who really cares?
And the first question was that they were like,
did you think you made an experiment on the audience?
And I didn't understand the question.
I probably gave a bad answer because I thought the person was criticizing me.
But I realized what they were saying was what you just said,
which was what we did.
And I think we are,
we earned it through the effort of not trying to push people too far.
So what you're saying I think,
I think,
well maybe some people will think we pushed too far,
but you know,
it's uh,
that's where it really comes down to a conversation about editing and,
um,
but it was weird cause I didn't anticipate their reaction.
I was,
I was so nervous in three acts are just sort of been like,
oh,
we're just doing this,
you know.
And it wasn't,
um,
but instead it was sort of people were,
people were having that same feeling of being hard to talk and that's what I
wanted to achieve,
but maybe had feared I had.
And just really quick to just to,
he also,
he also a senior editor as well as direct.
I see you've been watching it nonstop.
I can't watch the movie anymore.
You know,
I poked my head and it opened in theaters in La last Friday.
At the future I go to,
you know,
sometimes three times a week.
And so I was like,
I have to put it,
I've never seen any my own movies on the screen.
I like poked my head in there.
I was watching one scene and then I was like,
I shut down that you like,
there was a scene where like someone leaned back in the chair and I was like,
how come there's not a squeak?
They're like,
you can start seeing those things and then you're like,
that's why you can't watch the movie.
You know?
I think it's all,
I think I read in their interview,
I think it was all pounds a quarter on who was like,
who did gravity where he was like,
when I finished the film,
I watch it at the,
at the,
at the premiere with an audience and I never watched it again.
Oh,
right.
It's partly due to that and it's partly due to the,
I need to be here and speak about the film,
hopefully like in an engaging way.
And if I'm thinking about the three frames I should of caught between those
shots.
You can't,
and if there's something that you want to move,
if you want to be able to move on,
I'm not one of those people.
I don't,
I get really confused about the filmmakers would go back and recut their movies
years later.
I think it's,
there's something coming,
you know,
kind of,
I find something kind of no director's cuts out about it.
Yeah,
the director.
Well sometimes,
right.
Just cut us.
Cause the studios,
you know,
give you an opportunity to put your version of it.
In this case,
this is enough of my version that I wouldn't do it.
There's certainly some things that were contentious between me and the and the
producers of financing years,
but nothing I can't live with at the end of the day.
So it being a representative of the movie I wanted to make,
I think,
well I don't want to go back.
Yes,
of course.
I'm going to look back in 10 years.
I'll be like,
well I should have done a million things.
I look back in 10 months now.
Last even I want to change a million things,
but it was representative of the restrictions that I was under,
physically time,
money,
and it was a representative of who I was at 31 and all of these other things.
And you don't want to change that.
You just want to move on and then make the next one would,
let me learn and understand that.
And just to clarify,
when I,
when I mentioned being in the audience and wanting to,
wanting to be like,
you know,
wanting to get out,
right?
What I mean is I'm starting to plot with these prisoners.
I'm thinking,
how would I get out?
How would I go?
I leave.
No,
and I think,
I think you guys captured it.
I think you guys captured that incredibly well.
So what was it like for these prisoners?
How do they get out if they want it to?
There was a magical formula that human,
somebody committee said,
all they had to say is,
I quit the experiment.
If you say,
I went out,
I'm sorry,
I don't understand that language.
And they say,
I can't take it.
I'm sorry.
Wrong Ron Lang.
So,
so essentially,
um,
implicitly they are saying I quit the experiment,
but literally if they use that phrase,
they would have been released after day one.
The word experiments ceases to exist.
They say I want out.
Okay,
write a letter to the parole board.
So we had a parole board.
Now in the movie,
we only show one president every president,
every prison except one.
Oh Yep.
I've applied for the Parole Board and the parole board was headed by an ex
convict,
brilliantly played who had just got out of prison after 17 years,
who hated parole boards cause they had turned him down 16 years in a row.
And so he plays the role and he becomes his enemy.
And he says that he literally got sick.
He's a friend of mine,
Carlo Prescott got sick because he did this brilliant performance and
improvisational perform,
not for the camera,
but for now again at aired,
we had secretaries,
they showed,
they showed me in the staff,
there was not the case.
It was secretaries of different part of the building and the most dramatic thing
that happens at the end.
Uh,
he said,
okay,
take him away,
stand up.
And then we ask if we were to,
if we would have parole you,
would you be willing to forfeit all the money you have earned as a prisoner?
Everyone says yes.
The only reason they are is for 15 bucks a day.
They just said,
I don't want your money.
What should they have done?
I'm out of here.
And they take away,
they put the hands out,
the guards,
put the handcuffs,
put the bag and take them away.
At that point they are prisoners.
It's not an experiment.
Let's see.
I want to turn it over to the audience of one more question about the three
doctors in Bartow.
Just done a coming into the film and in having done a little research on it
beforehand,
I was really looking for the moment,
uh,
the turning point where,
I guess,
I guess motivations get changed.
I was looking for the moment where the guards crossed the line when,
when people change.
And so you talk about these being smart,
intelligent college students,
what does that change happen?
And I noticed,
I think twice in the film there's a moment where it gets a little physical,
it gets a little violent.
There's also a moment where somebody does try to get out.
And it seemed in those moments that the guards and your researchers,
everybody kind of looked to you and wanted to know what you thought would happen
next.
And in those moments initially before you obviously canceled,
you called it off six days in initially you said,
let's keep going,
let's let,
let's let it run.
Did you feel caught up in a moment that you feel like your own motivations for
change as well?
And there's no question.
I mean the main part of the study is um,
the most interesting part of this study for me,
the takeaway messages.
Everybody's kids.
Okay.
You know,
I'm uh,
I'm an old guy.
I'm 36,
I guess there are 38 years old and I'm a seasoned researcher and I get caught up
in the system I created.
And again,
it was by being the principal investigator,
you know,
I should have stopped it after the second kid broke down.
We proved our point.
But because I had in my mind,
we want to go for two weeks and a prisoner breakdown,
my job as principal vested is get a replacement.
So gallery placement,
um,
and uh,
take them the student out.
So,
so I got trapped in that role and is a scene.
Uh,
the real transformation was after visiting days,
parents had to see the superintendent.
So they came to my opposite superintendent and there's a scene where I become
something I hate.
I become a sexist.
Okay.
Meaning a mother and father come in,
the mother says to me,
I don't mean to make trouble sir.
Red Light,
Bang.
Nobody says that unless you've got to make.
And he says,
I've never seen my son looking so terrible.
And I said,
and then I saw at that moment I know she's going to blow the whistle.
I F I immediately flip and I do what every authority does.
I said,
what seems to be your son's problem?
Okay,
so I'm making a dispositional when we're studying the situation for us,
I know exactly what happened.
She said,
well,
you know,
he hasn't been sleeping.
As I said,
does he have insomnia again?
What's wrong with your kid?
She has no,
uh,
he told me they wake them up all hours of the night.
I said,
Oh yes,
of course we do.
That's the counts.
Each guard shift has to account for the fact that prisons have not escaped.
And then she says again,
I don't mean to make trouble.
What am I going to do?
Okay.
Who,
who's my cas?
There's the mother's going to make trouble.
And there's the father has been silent.
Both of them have just seen their kid looking terrible.
Okay.
I turned to the father,
what do I say?
Don't you think your son is tough enough to take
at that moment?
She's a silly little woman.
And,
and I think we probably did did.
I said,
you know,
guys shake.
And he said,
of course he is.
He's a real leader.
They kept at that moment,
you know,
he says,
come on honey.
Takes her away.
You know,
I felt so terrible cause I realized what I had just done.
I had big become again a sexist guy,
you know,
seizing the moment for what reason to save my prison because,
and she was going to make trouble and she would have,
he broke down that night.
He,
he's eight one nine hadn't had a break down that night and she was exactly
right.
And her husband,
the kids father sold him out.
And there was,
I remember when we were shooting that scene in the film that day,
um,
I'm sure
building downtown and there was like,
it was Saturday night and so people were started going up to the clubs that were
like nearby.
So there was literally like,
like there was like drunk people like banging on the doors in the building.
I go,
Hey,
what's going on?
Like what are you doing in there?
And,
and Billy was trying to,
you know,
work up sort of the,
that the anger you're talking about this woman and you can,
I could hear him on the mix and before he would run,
takes,
would say these things and stuff.
Like this is my experiment.
You're not taking this away from them.
What do you think you are?
You want me to say these things?
And there were so,
they were so great.
It was so fascinating to hear how you,
but you run those things are you,
you don't just think them,
but you say them out loud and then you kind of get that.
So he would sort of have that.
And nevertheless,
then there's like,
you know,
there's like drunk people like banging on the window.
Is that just sort of like came alive?
Yeah.
So again,
so here,
forget about the kids.
So he is,
um,
me getting into the role.
He has Carlo Prescott a season criminal,
a felon who again plays the role of the,
of the,
um,
uh,
parole board had and becomes that.
And the third character is,
there's a scene where Catholic Catholic priest comes in and talks to the kids.
I,
I tried to cross in the psychology of imprisonment in,
at Stanford in July with Carlo Prescott in order for me to learn about prisons.
And this priest heard about that and came to see me and my office hours said he
was doing a term paper on something.
Could I give him some references?
I said,
great deal.
How about you come,
I will do that.
How about you come down to this study and interview some of the prison is and
tell me how realistic it is.
Cause he had been a prison chaplain in a prison in Washington.
He comes down knowing it's an experiment and in two minutes he is the prison
chaplain.
And what you see in the movie is exactly what happened.
He says,
you know,
uh,
he introduced us up.
I'm probably the coffee.
What's your name,
son?
Almost every kid said the number,
I make one nine m two one six and then he says,
what are you in for?
And they said,
what do you mean what is your charge?
And again,
when,
when we had the police arrest,
the police always said one if a penal violation of penal code four 59 PC,
I'm robbery breaking.
And they gave that.
And then he says,
what are you doing to get out?
I look at is what he means.
I don't understand.
The words are exactly,
you're in jail,
what are you doing to get out?
And again,
he said,
you're a college student,
right?
You need a lawyer,
you're in jail.
And I'm looking at,
you know what I'm saying?
Wow.
He's really into it.
And he says this,
each kid,
the kid.
I mean,
so
and it's a different era too where priests represented something a little bit.
Yeah.
There's a,
yeah,
I was seven.
I mean it's three scandal.
Yeah.
Pre,
pre insets present.
Yeah.
You want to know,
and it was an interesting thing because even we were trying to cast that park.
A lot of the actors who came in played the nice priest.
Yeah.
And w the one guy who came in and understood that the scene was really more
that,
that it was,
not that he was a mean priest,
but he was like,
what are you here for?
What are you in foreign?
It's like that thing of like,
wait,
you're this prison.
And then also then the next day,
there was a,
this isn't in the film,
but there was a lawyer who came in who was somehow he called the lawyer,
one of the kids in the lawyer and something happened where no
one of the kids said,
oh,
that's right.
One of the kids said,
I have a cousin as a public defender.
He said,
well,
we should get him.
He said,
well,
uh,
I don't have his number here.
I call my mother.
So the kid gave the priest his mother's number,
the police call,
the mother mother called the public defender.
And then the real thing,
the public defender came down on Friday and that,
that's how I ended this thing.
And at that point it was
even the lawyer was using certain vernacular,
you know,
hey,
have you done your parole hearing at,
or let's start preparing what you're going to do.
You know what I mean?
It was,
uh,
there was a certain thing where that's what we're saying,
the power of the role you give yourself even just a little bit of that.
Yeah.
Ability to be that.
Then you become,
it.
Will we focused on the prisoners and guards.
But I'm saying,
here's the priests is a public defender.
Here's me,
here's a season at convict.
Everybody starts playing a role.
And that's really the message and you become the role.
And in fact,
you know,
in your life,
I mean,
you know,
who are you?
I,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a teacher,
I'm an educator.
I'm a Google code,
a coder.
I'm,
you know,
so,
and then that's,
that's your,
that's your job.
The job becomes your role and then it's your identity.
Who are you?
That's what you say.
Um,
fascinating.
Uh,
we'd love to turn it over to you guys for Q and a as well.
We want to end with this after Q.
Absolutely.
We're going to,
okay.
Uh,
my name is Daniel Steinberg.
And in with the experience of 40 years of,
of understanding of all this,
it seems as if Abu Ghraib should not have been a tremendous shock to those of us
who had followed any of this.
The question is,
is it possible when,
is there any example of a prison in which this kind of behavior can be avoided?
In.
Do any countries have prisons where they have a completely different paradigm
that works?
Yeah,
it's so present.
You know,
the most wonderful coincidence is that President Obama last week visited a
prison for the first time in the history of America.
No president in several hundred years ever visited a prison.
Meaning that whether or not you're liberal or not,
you know,
we are paying millions of dollars in taxes to maintain 2.3 million American
citizens in prison.
Uh,
and hopefully he's going to,
he's looks like he's going to try to push some prison reform.
Prisons are designed to punish.
They are not designed to rehabilitate that.
It's designed to educate.
Uh,
they are designed to punish.
Now when somebody,
when a jury or a judge gives a prison sentence,
the only sentence is you have lost your freedom for this period of time period.
It doesn't say,
and therefore we're going to Umilog.
Yet you therefore going to put you in solitary confinement.
Definitely.
We've got to punish you.
And the idea is you've got all these guys,
many of whom are uneducated,
have opportunity to educate them.
They're going to be there two year,
three years,
five years.
You could teach them coding,
you could teach them all kinds of stuff and you could teach them to original
presence.
We're called penitentiaries,
meaning you have time to think about the stuff you've done and be penitent about
it,
you know,
but the point that it's been so transformed into simply places of punishment
where prisoners come out,
most of them broken and hate to hate the system.
It turns out there's a prison.
It was a New York Times,
a few weeks in Norway,
uh,
which,
trains the guards and how to be compassionate,
uh,
trains their prisoners and how to be,
you know,
accept their role with dignity and apparently to have like no recidivism.
Um,
and uh,
I don't remember the name of it,
but it,
I know there's a prison in Norway that that does what you say.
And clearly we need to just a new model.
He need a,
a model.
Okay.
The other thing we should be concerned about is the data is that within three
years of being released,
60 to 70% of all prisoners released return.
On another crime,
in some cases,
even even more severe one,
that means that's the definition of failure,
you know,
so you'll let somebody out in three years later,
they're doing the same or worse thing again.
Oh,
I'm Melissa,
I'm Smith.
I'm a intern actually at Google this way.
And actually it's the calls you meet your,
so this is pretty fun.
Um,
as of Themis,
like psychology and psychology major where at George Mason and these great,
yeah,
of course.
So how do you feel about people associating you essentially only stands here,
Stanford prison experiment.
You've done lots of other research and lots of other really interesting things.
Like what,
no,
you're right.
I mean,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a little demonstration we did in six days and it's,
in one way it's a curse.
Um,
when I,
so I never wrote a book about it,
but after I did the study,
um,
I wrote a few articles,
it became famous instantly because of,
um,
uh,
serendipitous circumstances.
The day after we did our study on August 21st,
1971,
there was an alleged escape attempt of solar dad,
brother George Jackson from San Quentin,
and which he was killed,
people say murdered by the guards.
And,
but before he was,
he released all of his buddies from solitary confinement who then killed all the
informants,
killed some guards and prisoners were in the news.
Three weeks later,
Attica prisons at attic prisoners revolted again,
took over the prison.
First Time it took over the whole prison in sympathy to George Jackson's murder.
Uh,
and,
and suddenly there was a Senate Judiciary Committee on crime.
And here I am knowing nothing about prisons other than my base.
And I'm in Washington DC talking about prison reform.
I'm in San Francisco talking about juvenile justice.
Uh,
and,
but I should say you'll appreciate this.
Um,
so I'm sitting next to the Superintendent Mancuso of Attica,
uh,
Morgan Park of San Quentin,
the head of the guard union,
the head of prisoners,
a union.
I know nothing about prison.
So what do I do?
I say,
would you mind if I began by showing a slide show of the research we just did?
What that means is everybody now shares the same visual and from then on people
said as we saw in Zimbardo's prison guards the guard role.
Do you womanizers prisoners?
Not In this experiment.
He said as we saw in.
So suddenly I had status,
I didn't,
I didn't earn and,
and people attorney to me.
Well why do you think guards demonize prison?
They talking to me rather than superintendent around these other,
uh,
so that was again,
so this thing I feel about,
so the main thing I did right after the study is I began to study the psychology
of shyness in adults.
Before that psychologist only study China's the kids and they,
so this is called developmental psychologists.
They're cutoff point is 13.
When did you get to be 13 then somebody.
So it was as if when you're 13,
you stopped being shy.
No,
nobody studied you.
So I studied shyness as a self imposed psychological prison where the prison in
you says,
here's the list of things you can do and the the garden.
And the guard says,
which you can.
And the prison you says,
okay,
I deserve the raise,
but I won't ask the boss of them.
I know the answer I wanted.
I paid $10,
I know how to dance.
I won't ask the girl.
So,
so essentially,
and you ended up saying I'm worthless.
So I began to study shyness.
I had a shyness seminar at Stanford.
I started doing research on shyness and discovered that to be not shy is the
rare exception in the universe.
There's not more than five to percent of people in any country who are not shy.
So shine and people say,
I'm shy now.
I used to be shy,
outgrow it.
I'm shy.
And situation is the norm.
So we did research and then I started a clinic at Stanford and now it's in Palo
Alto University design,
exclusive retreat,
shyness.
And we get 90 a hundred percent cure because we know it's,
we know exactly what causes it.
We know how,
how to contain it,
we'd have to treat it.
So that's what I'm most proud of because it's,
it's an interesting idea.
Uh,
and we did research on it.
And then we ended up doing a play and then I wrote two books,
uh,
shyness,
what it is,
what to do about it,
and the shy child that sold,
you know,
written for the general public.
Right.
So that's my legacy.
Well,
I definitely feel a little,
um,
I felt like a little burdened by that.
I,
that idea too,
knowing how much he'd done outside of this experiment.
And part of the thing that,
you know,
when I came aboard,
I kind of had to say was,
okay,
we're only making movie about these six days.
If you made a film called the doctor Philip Zimbardo story,
it would be wildly different.
Right.
This would be one portion of it.
And you have to make that decision because you can't,
we could only afford one sentence that on a,
on a,
on a title card at the end of the film was really all we could do to try to
encapsulate that field.
Yeah.
And it was,
yeah.
and it was,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's just one of the challenges of making it into a movie.
And you can only hope that the movie leads people to the loser for a fact that
that then leads people to all these other things.
You can only,
you can only hope for that or engineer it to hopefully do that,
but you can't.
Uh,
the movie couldn't take on that responsibility being called the Stanford prison
experiment,
but it was definitely like a challenge to not include things like that.
Uh,
to what extent do you think the [inaudible] study experiment come used us
explore commentary,
excuse for evil doers,
like people knowing that there is this situational you voided or will affect
their behavior.
Thank you.
That's a good point.
So that's what ties to a grade.
Um,
uh,
when I'm agreeing happened in 2004,
um,
somebody made a lot of money and releasing 12 film,
12 images that the soldiers had taken.
So these were army ring service.
They were not real soldiers and that's really key.
Um,
they were army reservists,
uh,
military police guards in the,
in the basement and Aba Grade,
uh,
on the night shift tier one.
And,
um,
it turns out they were 12 or more than a thousand images.
Many of the images that were not released or much worse.
And what happened was I had a form of Stanford student who was working at NPR
and I happened to be in Washington,
called me and said,
hey doc,
does EDC those hit me?
I said,
no.
He said,
they're right out of the prison study.
God's putting bags over his head,
stripping him naked and having them simulate,
you know,
sexual activities,
do you want to come and talk about it?
So I did an interview the next day at NPR and I said,
look,
I,
I know nothing about that situation,
but there's enough similarity.
It looks like the Stanford prison study on steroids because in our study went
for six days.
This went for three months.
They've used this to place over an extended period of three months.
And,
and I said,
you know,
um,
I want to believe American soldiers are good apples.
Cause you,
you remember the,
uh,
the military and the Bush administration,
these are a few rogue soldier,
a few bad apples.
Whenever there's a scandal,
the system protects itself.
I say don't blame us,
blame them.
And I said,
my concern is somebody put the are good apples and really bad barrels.
So we want to know who did that.
And those are the bad barrel makers.
So when we want to understand any human behavior,
it's not enough to make a dispositional individual analysis.
We have to do a situational analysis and then we have to put the situation in a
systemic context.
So that's the first time I use.
So bad apples,
bad app,
bed bowels,
bed barrel makers.
Uh,
and,
and that took off.
So then I became an expert witness for the guard who should've been in charge of
the night shift a chip Frederick.
And in my testimony I said,
uh,
this as the presiding judge,
you're on a chip.
Frederick is guilty as charged.
The fact that he did this in this unique situation does not change his guilt or
innocence.
So you can't have,
the situation is not excused theology.
But I can say with all expert confidence that he never would have done that had
he not been put in that situation.
Because I studied his entire life from the time he was born to now he's an
outstanding soldier,
patriotic won many awards and they put him in this situation,
which is
the most extreme situation I could imagine.
I won't go through the details with,
you know,
he worked 12 hour shifts when he finished his shift.
He slept in a prison cell in a different part of the prison because the prison
was under bombardment and also the abuse has happened only on the night shift.
Nine of nine guards and the,
I shifted these things,
taking these pictures,
you know,
putting prisons naked in pyramids,
etc. None on the day shift.
How could that be?
So that's a situational variable.
Zero of nine,
nine of nine.
It turns out the head of military police,
I'm sorry,
the head of military intelligence goes to the head of the military police and
Ann Arbor grave and says we're not getting any actionable intelligent.
We're interrogating all these guys were getting nothing.
And the military,
the Bush administration is on our s the guys on your night shift have to take
the gloves off.
So you always use euphemisms.
Take the gloves off,
they have to break the president.
So when we interrogate them,
they'll spill the beans.
Okay.
So essentially you're giving them total power.
And in three months is no,
no evidence that any senior office ever went down to the dungeon.
So you're telling me I do what the fuck ever you want and nobody's going to
notice except when we interrogate them.
Hopefully they're going to,
they're going to give information.
And on the day shift,
senior officers were there all the time.
So essentially the message there is power without oversight.
Powers out.
Surveillance is a recipe for abuse.
It.
So the worst abuse at Sanford happened at night because some,
sometimes I had,
I slept in my office upstairs,
so I never,
I never left the situation with that for that week.
So,
so that's the message you give people absolute power and without oversight,
without limits,
without constraints,
over time that power will be abused.
And so,
so my,
my testimony reduced his sentence from 15 years to eight,
then we're going to give him 15 years.
Uh,
and the worst they did physically,
he had a prison once.
But he,
but he allowed a lot of the,
uh,
the Dick degrading images of the grading practices.
Um,
after you did the Stanford prison experiment,
I'm wondering,
did you reflect on classic works of Literature,
like Lord of the flies and the similarities and what did you make of that
intersecting?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I taught a lot of the plaza.
I've written about it.
Um,
uh,
and it's just,
you know,
it's a brilliant golden state.
It's a really brilliant analysis of ordinary kids,
you know,
put,
put in a new situation where essentially if you remember,
democracy takes over it.
At first,
the good kid,
the big kids protect the little kids.
And then the message is ultimately fascism rules.
Authoritarians take over.
All you need is one or two.
Uh,
and,
and there's a dramatic scene in the movie where,
um,
I knew it.
So,
um,
one of,
one of the guys strips himself naked and put and then paints himself with a
color and he gets the other guys to change their appearance.
And at that point all hell breaks loose.
I actually did research on deindividuation following that.
Meaning,
what happens when you make girls feel anonymous and their job is to shock other
women.
I mean college students Shockey other women versus when they feel identifiable,
they gave twice as much electric shock,
held their finger down in a shock button twice as long when they were anonymous.
So,
so I did that study before the prison study based on,
on Lord of the flies.
You know.
So again,
good literature taps into good psychology and what I try to do is have good
psychology.
It map onto good literature
reference that too.
When we were shooting the film,
the last scene when,
when this is character comes in and says the experiment's over,
you know,
we talked a lot about their reaction that it was a really hard thing to get and
they get guys just did it right,
which is sort of a sense of relief.
But we talked a lot about that.
What happens at the end when they show up and they're saved,
they immediately resort back to like almost like an infant tile.
The way it's written,
they start like crying and wailing and they even start acting younger than their
age and it's this interesting thing of how quickly you can fall down this hole
and then how quickly our bodies get out of it too is really that in a weird way
that's almost as alarming is that it bothers people.
For instance,
at the end of the film it says they all,
none of them suffered to me longterm abuse.
People that don't want to understand the other co,
all the reviews I read,
they're like,
well yeah,
sure.
That's what the filmmakers want us to believe.
And it's a,
well no,
that's just the truth.
Many of them were not someone onto beads,
psychologists,
prison psychologist,
you know,
none of that.
None of these guys went on to be criminals or you know,
had any kind of institutionalization or anything.
And so it's an interesting thing and I remember talking to Director of
compliance,
which is a,
a subject matter,
which is about the fast food hoax that doctors about her has written about too.
And his film we had on our side the benefit of the,
this being much more famous.
So people were like,
oh,
people know it really happened.
But after compliance,
premier people were furious at him because they didn't want to believe it was
true.
And he was like,
they were mad at me because they were mad at the story in the movie.
But so they were mad.
They didn't put an,
except they were mad at the stories that they were mad at the movie.
And then in turn were mad at me and you can't say,
well,
it was real.
You can only say so much to someone because they don't want to believe it.
Yeah.
Just very briefly,
I'm a,
I'm not sure how many people know.
I think it was the compliance as they're rolling in there.
So there was this fast food hoax
that was the name of the film.
Yeah.
I don't know what the overall,
yeah.
Um,
in 27 different states in United States,
some guy calls a fast food restaurant,
all different kinds of mcdonalds,
whatever,
and says one of your employees is it says,
I'm Sergeant Johnson.
I'm Captain Johnson.
Uh,
we have evidence at one of your employee,
one of your new employees,
uh,
has,
been stealing it's contraband.
We think it's related to drugs.
Uh,
uh,
you could either you need to send it down to police station or you can wait and
we'll come and pick her up.
And they said,
which one?
Well,
the new one or the Brunette.
Oh,
Jenny.
Yeah,
that's the one.
It's Jenny.
He did,
he's making us happy.
He's in a phone booth.
And then what happens?
Then you say,
well,
bring it,
bring it to you security area,
uh,
and hold there for questioning.
And they do.
So now you have security cameras are covering this.
And then he says,
okay,
now why were you there?
Why didn't you begin?
So this is a female and put a stripper naked,
you know,
do it.
Do an initial search and tell it and tell us what you're doing.
And then in some cases,
the woman says,
well,
I've got to go back to the floor.
He said,
you know,
do you have anybody who could cover you?
You have a husband,
a boyfriend,
and this was,
yeah,
I have my fiance comes and now here's this guy with a naked woman and the,
and the guy who's a wire,
I said saying,
okay,
now I want you to follow my orders.
Uh,
she may have something under your breath,
so feel under her breath.
She may have something in her anus,
something I'd be,
so he's now this poor girl,
18 year old girl.
He's is that we're doing the sexual stuff and then finally ends up okay.
Uh,
uh,
um,
we,
we still think she's guilty,
so I want to punish her.
So make,
make a,
have oral sex on you.
It's all caught on security camera all.
And he was finally caught,
uh,
by really good detective work.
But it's not one guy when,
I mean it's one guy,
but it's 27 different places.
And everybody sees the film,
blames the woman in the film who is the,
the security manager.
And she,
she just says,
you know,
he was really convincing.
I,
you know,
I'm just following orders like I do as a sick,
as you know,
a low level employee.
And Mcdonald's,
we follow orders.
People say do this stuff.
And nobody wanted to believe is that the same thing?
So they,
they were angry at the film maker.
They were angry at this woman.
No,
I think you gotta be angry at,
is this guy going after she got off?
Because it was,
it was,
it was from the time he was arrested,
these things stopped.
But there was,
there was only circumstantial evidence.
The good news is the woman who was the woman is abused,
got a big court settlement
and as an appropriate transition,
I promise that.
And with one final question and I'll,
I'll ask it to you both but in a different way.
I'll let you guys decide.
So for,
for you,
I'll ask both of you.
Good for you.
It's the classic,
what do you want people to take away from the film?
And what I'll address similarly,
doctors on board really quickly is sharing.
The way this came up was before we sat down,
I told Doctor Zimbardo that whenever a Kitty Genovese,
he comes up this trial nigger Milgram's experiment comes up.
I am that guy in the room.
It's is no,
I wouldn't do it.
I wouldn't have done that.
I would've gone that far.
I wouldn't,
I would have helped the person need,
I would not have let the situation affect who I am.
I'm always that guy in the room.
And so the question there as well,
you know,
talk about the hero training that you're doing.
It almost surprises me what you just said,
that you should blame the guy on the phone with exclusively.
Is it not also on those of us in society to stand by our morals and risk,
public ridicule to do what we think is the right thing?
That's my hand question.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was,
uh,
let's take away from the phone,
but honestly,
I had one goal which was just con conversation.
I didn't want the movie to tell you what you should be talking about.
Those experiments still relevant 40 44 years later.
And it's relevant because every,
it's always relevant,
you know,
and so I didn't want the movie to narrow that in or say,
oh,
look at what happened at Arbor Gray.
But I didn't want to contextualize it in our history because I wanted to move
into,
to sort of be able to exist always.
And so for me it's just if it leads to conversation than it's great,
you know?
To me that's,
that's the,
that was the number one goal or I shouldn't say fruitful conversation obviously.
You know what I mean?
It leads to saying I fucking hated that movie.
That's not a conversation you want it.
But you know,
for me it was,
and that's the goal of the,
I just don't want to ever make a movie that you forget,
you know,
10 minutes later.
And in this case it's hopefully leads to hopefully people look up the experiment
and it leads them to more understand.
Absolutely.
I think we all did.
Yeah.
Present exp.org is a great website that we've been,
I've been involved with like 20 years and we've just redone,
it has everything there is about the prison,
prison study,
prisons,
etc. And so what I would like,
but I would like to take away is the flip.
So here I created evil.
Seek criminologist,
sociologist study evil from the outside in.
I mean,
interview,
interview criminals,
you visit prisons.
I wanted to create evil from the inside out that it's put good people in a bad
place and say,
you know who wins?
Does a good people?
If you have a bad place filled with good people,
shouldn't they dominate or if the bad place,
uh,
is really bad and evil doesn't the place when and humanity lose.
And that,
unfortunately,
that's a conclusion.
And in this study in the movie,
there are no heroes except the woman who challenges me confronts me to say,
what you're doing is wrong.
That these are not present as a not guards at boys and as suffering.
It's your fault.
And in,
in the real experiment,
she then says,
we had just moved in and it shows it,
which is true.
The beginning of the,
of the movie,
uh,
she says,
if this is the real you,
I don't want to continue my relationship.
We had just moved in.
We were planning to get married.
And so that's her role.
She's willing to give up a romantic relationship,
marital relationship for a moral principle about kid.
She doesn't even know.
But she's,
she saw the suffering.
And so,
so for me,
so that's really heroic.
So a hero is somebody who comes to the aide of others in need and or defends a
moral cause,
aware that his costs.
So altruism is heroism.
Light.
You're giving money to church,
you get,
but it doesn't cost you.
So heroes a rare only because people in weighing the situation and say it's not
worth it.
So whistle blowers are proactive heroes that you see fraud,
you'll see corruption.
You have to collect data off,
you have to get people on your side.
Most heroes are really more impetuous,
uh,
react.
You react to the situation like the famous hero in New York,
the subway hero guy falls on attracts,
he jumps on the railroad track,
puts the guy between the tracks as the train goes over them for half an inch,
he would have been a dumb dead hero.
He would cut his head off.
He so,
so essentially.
So,
so when we finish this study,
I be getting,
I mean,
so when I started writing looser effect,
I realize that I know nothing about heroes because I started to lose it.
I sought the last chapter is how do you resist these powerful forces in all the
research and all the studies of evil in the real world,
in Holocaust,
in Bosnia,
Rwanda,
there's always a small percentage,
had five,
10 men,
never more than 30 of people who do it resist.
I won't go along.
They don't go along,
and some cases they not only don't go along,
they challenged the eval and I said,
you know,
I know I don't know anything about heroes.
I never thought about it.
And I should have given this woman who challenged me.
We've been married for 44 years.
So I began to do research and literally library research and Harrison turns out
the word hero and heroine,
some does not exist in any psychology textbook.
It's not part of the positive psychology movement because a compassion and
empathy are virtues.
Heroism is a civic action.
So essentially IBM to say,
Hey,
wait a minute.
What good is compassion action if it doesn't lead to action,
because action is what changes the world.
So I started seven years ago in San Francisco,
a nonprofit called the heroic imagination project.
The simple goal is to teach people,
all people,
especially young people,
to learn how to express the inner hero that you all have,
especially as kids who really had this inner hero,
not through superheroes,
which is dramatic but the wrong direction because superheroes don't have the
most important thing in the world.
And every kid has is a brain.
They are the creation of somebody with a creative brain.
So,
so he said,
you have something that they don't have.
And with your brain you could create anything.
So essentially we're going to teach you how to be a wise and effective hero,
how to analyze social situations,
um,
uh,
how,
how to take wise and effective action.
But the point is we want to inspire you to always take the right action,
stand up,
speak out in challenging situations,
studying in your family and your school and your community.
And then we have training program.
We teach people how to do this.
And then the other thing we do is I started education and a revolution
education.
We have a number of lessons about the bison effect about,
I know Carol Dweck was here from Stanford last week.
How do you transform a fixed mindset,
which you say I'm good or not good at this.
Uh,
to a growth mindset.
I'm good at anything.
If I put enough practice and effort,
how do you reverse prejudice had to change groups that have a negative
influence,
the positive.
So we call this understanding human nature and we have six of these programs.
We hope to have uh,
four more conservation sustainability.
But what's revolutionary is teachers don't teach.
We give them a script and all the programs organized around powerful videos
cause kids live individual where we show a video and instead of having class
discussion,
the teacher has pairs,
pairs or triads.
And we try to have a boy and a girl together cause boys never answered in class.
Girls I was doing.
And,
and,
and so essentially you show her the video of a failure of bystander.
And then you say,
what were the people thinking?
Why didn't they help?
What would you do?
What's the difference?
He lucky in a situation being in that we showed them the kitty Genovese video
and then we say,
you know,
how does anybody study this?
That we show them video of social psychology,
study this.
And then we say,
you know,
when should you help?
When should you not help?
Uh,
uh,
and then think of a time when you helped.
Then you have a time when you didn't help.
And then we go through.
So each,
each of the six programs has the same eight activities.
So once the teacher learns to do one,
it's easy to transfer.
And then the key is at the end you say,
okay,
spread the word.
That's activity eight.
What does that mean?
What's the most interesting thing you learned today?
And the kid writes it now tell somebody and they write to tell your mother,
your cousin,
bus driver,
the grocery man.
And they teach teaching in the next week is,
what did your mother say?
My mother was,
couldn't believe.
How could it be that when there's a lot of people around,
nobody helps.
It's better to have just one.
Now go back,
ask your mother if she could tell one other person.
So now this little lesson,
which we now Henry remote areas in Hungary,
you know,
some mother is telling the butcher and I'm not in the minus their notebook.
So in that sense,
it's really a revolution in education.
Um,
and the problem we have is we started here.
We can not get a program in any San Francisco high school because the high
schools,
they say,
you know,
if it's not stem,
if it's not preparing for the exams,
we can't work it in.
So our program is in all of the Hungary.
It's all over Poland.
It's in Corleone,
the Godfather town in Sicily.
And um,
you know,
so,
so right now we're trying to,
um,
uh,
we just applied for a Google community grant because I have virtually no staff.
W W W we have a hero factory in my basement.
We're creating these little little heroes.
Uh,
so we needed staff.
We need,
we need a sophisticated help,
uh,
to move it to the next level.
So we have the material,
we have the desire and the inspiration.
Wonderful.
Well,
thank you both.
Called us on board are great to see you.